[Musique]
petite session surf sur les pentes du
markstein
depuis le 6 janvier le domaine est
ouvert aux amateurs de glisse mais pas
que sur la station haut rhinoise vous
pourrez aussi pratiquer les activités
nordiques le kite surfing la randonnée
en raquettes et même découvrir les
environs un chien de trait
qu'on ait une station qui présente 230
mètres de dénivelé on a huit remontées
mécaniques plus une piste de luge sur
rail en un domaine skiable à peu près 60
hectares avec un bon tiers enneigées de
culture avec un enneigement de
complément donc qui permet de pallier à
certains manques on a quand même une
chance par rapport à pas mal d'autres
stations c'est qu'on a une attitude qui
est élevé à l'échelle du massif
on n'a aucune piste qui est en dessous
de 1000 mètres et on monte à apprendre à
1267 mettre un au sommet de nos pistes
donc ce qui nous permet de nous
préserver de certains de certains redou
après il ya aussi des aléas comme on est
vraiment sur la crête parfois un peu
plus devant les redoux certains redou
quand il ya beaucoup de vent chaud sont
parfois un peu plus un peu plus incisif
qu'à d'autres endroits mais globalement
notre altitude est un atout accueillant
jusqu'à deux mille visiteurs par jour
lors des pics de fréquentation
la station s'est joué de ses nombreux
atouts tant auprès des ce qui confirmait
que des débutants
le markstein a une réputation de station
sportive mais c'est également un très
très beau domaine d'initiation pour la
découverte du ski et la progression sur
sur les coûts alors au niveau du
markstein on a un atout essentiel c'est
l'espace initiation donc c'est parmi un
des plus grands du des vosges donc on a
tout de même 4 téléski et des belles
pistes bien large pour tous les
débutants près performance il ya
possibilité aussi puisqu'on a un stade
de slalom on est très bien équipée de ce
côté là mais effectivement pour tout ce
qui est débutant même jusqu'à chez nous
un facilement troisième étoile est un
tout petit peu plus haut il ya largement
de quoi satisfaire tous les publics
en 2001 la station était au bord du
dépôt de bilan
le conseil départemental intervient
alors pour la sauver de nombreux
investissements réalisés au titre de la
politique montagne le département du
haut rhin a engagé en 2002 une politique
de développement de la montagne une
politique été hiver et le markstein a eu
la chance de pouvoir s'inscrire dans ce
dispositif
il en a profité à peu près à hauteur de
5 millions d'euros depuis 2002 avec des
investissements relativement important
depuis 2010 des travaux sur les pistes
des travaux au niveau du départ de vol
libre parce qu'il faut savoir aussi que
le markstein est un site important au
niveau du vol libre et des travaux
également sur
une nouvelle luge sur rail qui a
remplacé un vieux bob luge complètement
obsolète et ce qu'on voit un petit peu
moins des travaux sur une nouvelle
station d'épuration
donc on est à peu près à un peu plus de
3,4 millions d'euros d'investissement
c'est clair ces quelques dernières
années
[Musique]
ce
des investissements qui portent
aujourd'hui leurs fruits la station
c'est au total une soixantaine d'emplois
en saison d'hiver un peu moins en été
tant du point de vue touristique
qu'économique
le markstein est un élément structurant
territoire
[Musique]
le martian est un site reconnu je pense
pas partout c'est un site de proximité
c'est un site facile d'accès on y accède
par la vallée de thann comme celle de
guebwiller très facilement
c'est c'est un des critères les plus
importants je pense pour pour faire
marcher aujourd'hui le site c'est son
accessibilité à cette station c'est le
bassin de vie de toute une clientèle de
proximité donc le grand bassin
mulhousien les vallées bien entendu mais
également une clientèle touristique
c'est vrai que depuis quelques années on
a quand même le massif de par sa
particularité il n'y a pas que du ski il
ya d'autres activités on commence à
toucher une clientèle un peu plus
familial et il commence à y avoir de
plus en plus de touristes à proprement
parler donc des gens qui viennent un peu
plus loin avec bien entendu beaucoup de
personnes du benelux aujourd'hui le site
fait le plein été comme hiver l'objectif
de développement est remplie reste des
aménagements à réaliser pour pérenniser
ce succès le dossier peut-être le plus
important est celui de l'accueil du
public sur le site donc de revoir là
l'installation de la maison d'accueil
delà de la rénover ou delà de la
réhabiliter également de voir tout ce
qui est voirie et stationnement
également au niveau du ski nordique
l'accueil de ski nordique est également
difficile actuellement il après il
s'agit de trouver les investissements à
faire donc je pense qu'il y à il y à du
travail sur le site du markstein pour
mettre à niveau pour rattraper les
investissements qui n'ont pas encore pu
être fait et ensuite c'est l'objectif
premier c'est de satisfaire la clientèle
et les investissements nécessaires non
seulement son important pour la
clientèle hivernale à mais également
pour la clientèle estivale
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que le
markstein et quand même situé sur la
route des crêtes qui est un axe majeur
de fréquentation touristique estivale
élément incontournable des vosges
alsaciennes le markstein s'inscrit dans
un paysage à fort potentiel touristique
et quelque part
le markstein il est un petit peu ce
point de départ de d'une politique est
en train de se construire au niveau au
niveau des hautes vosges au niveau des
vosges haut rhinoise et alsaciennes
notamment avec le projet de grande crête
où on organise un peu la liaison entre
les différents sites touristiques de des
vosges sur le long de la route des
crêtes
donc ça commence dans notre canton avec
avec le hartmannswillerkopf là aussi
avec un fort potentiel culturel
historique mémorielle et puis ensuite
fur et à mesure différentes activités le
markstein typé sport type et loisirs et
puis plus loin ensuite d'autres d'autres
activités
[Musique]
en tout cas pour ceux qui ne pourraient
plus attendre pour chausser les skis
toute l'équipe du markstein vous donne
rendez sur les pistes
[Musique]